we're genius meets possibility you may
not love snakes that you'd be happy to
see one of these snake robots if you
were trapped in a collapsed building at
least that's what how he chose it
thought when he began making snake
robots to locate survivors with help
from the National Science Foundation now
as for the real McCoy I'm afraid of
snakes chosen and his team at Carnegie
Mellon are now working on snake-like
surgical devices become denominator with
all the snake robot applications is
performing a task in a confined space
Curnutt surgical devices are either too
rigid or two flexible a snake bot is
both making complicated heart surgeries
possible with less trauma to the patient
well fortunately this snake doesn't bite
at least yet and if this one gives me
any trouble I can read button that was
easy I'm Miles O'Brien